I think that's the first time has been a
double isn't it for a Best Supporting
Actor and then the best leading one
if one reads the newspapers or listens
to the news it is quite obvious that the
whole world is having a nervous
breakdown in the motion picture industry
we do not thank God
contribute to the shambles by
manufacturing tanks flamethrowers or
rockets we do something to try and help
keep people saying we turn out
entertainment the award for the best
picture is never likely given and now to
divulge the contents of this year's most
important envelope is a very important
contributor to world entertainment and
someone quite likely
you didn't
Oh
well general Nachum that was almost
bound to happen but isn't it fascinating
that fascinating to think that the
probably the only love that man will
ever get in his life was by stripping
off and showing his shortcomings
if them if I might continue with the
introduction of very important worldwide
and much beloved entertainer I'll give
you a little hint as to who it is
because she's someone perhaps who is
likely to have not only breakfast but
luncheon and dinner at Tiffany's miss
Lizabeth Taylor
that's a pretty hard act to follow
you